all right welcome back it's another
trial by social media that's looking
like it's turning out to be completely
wrong a pregnant New York City nurse is
striking back after getting smeared all
over the internet as a racist Karen it's
over a viral video showing her calling
for help while a group of black teens
are accusing her of stealing their
rental bike
here
[Music]
um
The Usual Suspects piling on with all
sorts of character assassinations the
famed civil rights lawyer Ben Crump
saying that this is quote exactly the
type of behavior that has endangered so
many black men in the past the hospital
that employs her calling the video
disturbing and of course they placed her
on leave while the review is underway
the nurse is now in hiding getting death
threats but her lawyer is fighting back
with evidence blowing up the entire
narrative
these receipts show that she rented the
bike the serial numbers matched what's
that play is what social media did to
this woman who is literally a hero and
has done nothing but help people and
within one minute effectively tries to
ruin her do they allege this is racism
that's what the media portrays and
that's what it looks like that's what
that's what her employer is saying here
correct that's what it looks like we
have no ill will towards these young men
in fact we wish them the best our Focus
here is on the media who defend her
Lawrence when I watched that video why
did you come to me first go ahead no go
ahead I came to you first because I want
to know what your perspective is on this
when I watched that video
I've had two kids pregnant women hold a
special place in my heart if I'm on the
train and there's a pregnant woman
having a bad day even if she's got an
attitude it's in my nature to back up
and just let her have the seat or to let
her have the room I know she's probably
going through it I know that her
emotions are high or can be and although
there's a lot going on there that I
don't understand when you watch that
video do you see that from her or do you
see someone who's hateful and trying to
trap someone else you know I I don't
look at it just from the video because
if you just look at the video you don't
know the facts of what happened I mean I
I didn't say anything about this video
for that exact reason and now we're
getting other accounts of what actually
took place
um the attorney alleges that
she had already purchased the bike the
allegation that came out originally was
that the boys had purchased the bike and
then they would be liable for the bike
if she took off with the bike the
tourney says I have two receipts Bill
Himmler said he looked at those receipts
and it shows two purchases for that bike
matched up to the serial number
um if that is true
what they did to her is asinine the
compare just so people understand the
historical moment that they were
comparing this to they were comparing
this to Emmett Till who was brutally
murdered
by an allegation of a white woman that
he raped her and it wasn't true that
lady just died she was 90 something
years old to compare this situation in
purposely and no that's not the case I
think we have gone down as just a crazy
slippery slope in society I don't know
all the facts right here but if Bill
Himmler said that he looked at both of
the receipts
I I trust this reporting on this and
this is messed up I think she should sue
them all yeah sue them all Katie he said
if he said if what they're reporting is
true if these receipts match up if I
watch that video and don't add any other
context as to what so-and-so said the
receipts are the other thing what I see
are at its very best two people having a
legitimate argument over who paid for
the bike first why is it that we're in a
society where that's what it goes for
because people like Ben Crump want to
inject race into a situation so they can
profit and benefit off of it when it
doesn't exist and the fact that people
like Ben Crump and the people on on
Twitter and their allies in the media
ran with that narrative that she was
somehow racist or having this
altercation and that she was the one who
was stealing from black men and putting
them into a position of harm and that's
why black men in America have had a hard
time it is blood boiling it is not true
she's six months pregnant
um to add on to all of that and the idea
that they injected race where it doesn't
belong doesn't hurt the cause or it
doesn't help the cause for equality and
for understanding it only helps the
pocketbooks for Ben Crump and I hope
that she I think she is suing everybody
and I hope that there is some
accountability because it doesn't help
the the conversation and the environment
among Americans when they do this to a
situation that has nothing to do with
race but make it all about that it
really is Despicable judge when I see a
video that's a minute long or a minute
and a half long and everyone's taking a
hot take on it my reaction at this point
is to cool the Jets and say what's the
rest of the information absolutely when
someone like Ben Crump who understands
law comes out and tweets something like
that is he making himself liable is he
exposed are people that made judgments
even the hospital putting her on leave
is there a legal precedent for her to
say I've got the receipts pay up well
yeah if she feels that people defamed
her as she's a thief they're alleging
that she's a thief that she stole a bike
from people who actually paid for it she
didn't pay for it then you've got the
issue of I understand there was a tussle
um and I don't know how much whether
there's more of this video or not where
she says you know I'm pregnant and they
say things like you know stop your fake
crying and you know your baby's gonna
come out this way I mean there was some
mean mean things that were said I don't
like it when the race baiters come out
the race Vaders Who come out looking to
make money on something like this that's
the lowest of the low as far as I'm
concerned now what they did was they
also they kept fighting her for the bike
she's trying to get on the bike and then
they push the bike back so it's locked
in again as to make it look as though
you know it really is theirs they can
take it from the start the bike is worth
twelve hundred dollars okay if they took
that from her I mean she could be
charged twelve hundred dollars for a
bike that was stolen but even worse is
that I don't like the way they treated
this nurse yeah nurses during the
pandemic were literally God's angels on
Earth and then all of a sudden we said
you know what you don't get the vaccine
even though you risked your life you're
going to lose your job and then when we
decided that we don't need the vaccine
they didn't hire those nurses that they
fired and I'm really upset with New York
City what is it it's health and Health
Services for putting her on leave why
are they putting her on leave she lost a
lot she should sue
Jessica let's as much benefit of the
doubt as humanly possible say it was a
legitimate argument over the bike yep
did your mind go straight to race is
that what you see when you watch this
video are those legitimate complaints
about the video that Ben Crump and
people like that have put out there it's
certainly a valid
perspective on it when you look at it
you can see it's one white person and
there are five black people but I I
certainly didn't go to that my my
immediate reaction is someone who was
pregnant not too long ago is I would be
scared out of my mind and when they say
get your stomach off of me it's it's a
very uncontrollable period in your life
your body when you're pregnant and you I
mean there's a reason pregnant women
when I was pregnant I sat at the table
every day with my hands here you just
instinctually are protecting what it is
that you're growing inside of her so my
first thought was that I would never
tell where we all felt like we should
protect what it is that's I mean like as
men and that's why I went to you first
as young men shouldn't we have it in us
to want to protect that vulnerable woman
I mean shouldn't that be a part of who
we are of course and but that doesn't
mean that there wasn't a valid
disagreement in this and that we
shouldn't see how this played out and it
brings up two issues that are important
to me one I really want a moratorium on
comparing things to atrocities of the
past where it doesn't work I don't want
to hear Emma tell
on its own I don't want to hear Jim Crow
2.0 I don't want to hear anyone compared
to a KKK wizard these we can sign up for
new new words for these things let's
hope you speak at the DNC convention
I am available I don't know how to dance
but
um definitely do that let it play out
and I think that her employer is
honestly trying to protect her what
happens then is a lot of people who live
nowhere near her who don't know her
don't know what type of person she is
weighs in on this through social media
it wasn't just a way in they went to go
find her yeah tomorrow my social media
they put her on leave calling the video
disturbing right but after they've
reached out Hey listen facts will
continue to come great all right ahead
squatter Insanity in America gets worse
military vets are coming home to find
someone else living in their homes hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now